he's the best there is at what he does
and what he does is design MCU
characters a set of renderings of
Wolverine drawn by former Disney artist
Jason Pastrana in 2017 is making the
rounds on the internet and anticipation
of the x-men's eventual introduction to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe several
pieces were posted to Pastor Ana's
Instagram and while it's far from the
only Marvel concept art on his page his
reimagined movie Wolverine may be the
most intriguing Disney didn't officially
acquire the film and television assets
of Fox Studios until earlier this year
so at the time this artwork was
commissioned the notion of the x-men
entering the MCU was not much more than
speculation
even so pastirada went to the trouble of
designing at least nine different takes
on Wolverines iconic mask and you'll
notice that all of them downplay the
parts of the mask resembling the points
of his hair which sometimes seemed to
stretch into infinity in some of the
characters comic-book depictions it's
worth noting the to stealth variants
with the mouth and nose covered a
version with an axe on the forehead and
the presence of a great big stinky
stogie in every version where the mouth
is visible odds our Disney would have
nixed that detailed past Rana eventually
settled on a version he liked something
of a combination between designs number
two and five and designed the entire
costume front and back as iconic as Hugh
Jackman's long run as Wolverine and the
Fox produced movies was the character
has never even come close to looking
like this in a movie you actually go
outside what would you prefer yellow
spandex this version of Wolverine is a
lot closer to what we're familiar with
from the comics he looks older downright
grizzle as if the MCU version of
Wolverine would start out as aged and
Haggard as the one in Logan rather than
ending there the rendering of the face
even looks a little bit like Jackman
it's enough to make you wonder if at
some point Disney execs were kicking
around the notion of porting over the
Fox version of the x-men to the MCU
before deciding to recast everyone
except Deadpool
don't scratch cleaning up the timeline
since pastirada drew these concepts in
2017 names that have been bandied about
as possible successors the Jackman skew
much younger than the depictions here
look
rocket man's Taron Egerton de coeur
montgomery from stranger things and even
Daniel Radcliffe of Harry Potter Fame
have all been rumoured to be considered
for Wolverine but pasture owners work is
definitely worth consideration it seems
to be a clever way to fit Logan into the
MCU note the compact streamlined look of
the helmets and the utilitarian feel of
the uniform which invokes an aesthetic
similar to the duds worn by agents of
shield or superheroes with a more
militaristic vent there's even a short
belt pouch or if we're being less
charitable a fanny pack with a little X
on it it's not hard to imagine another
MCU character making some kind of
wisecrack about that Pastrana apparently
does this kind of stuff all the time and
if you visit his Instagram you will
absolutely get lost in it other designs
of his include an MCU version of Doctor
Doom a rendering of riri Williams better
known as iron hearts and a version of
spider-man if his suit had been designed
not by Tony Stark but by Sheree it'd
definitely be cool if at least some
elements a pastor honest design make it
to the big screen because again it's a
version of Wolverine who seems to fit
the MCU s setting we have the distinct
feeling that he'd do the team justice if
you were to put his mind to designing
their MCU look because what do you know
he already did it and it's a really
smart take that said pastor onna doesn't
work for Disney any more so it's more
than likely another concept artists will
provide their own designs for Marvel's
mutants and we'll have to wait several
years to find out if the characters
eventual designs resemble pastor Ana's
handiwork or go in an entirely different
direction Marvel Studios has not
announced the release dates of any x-men
projects as of yet check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the MCU are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you